ok hello everyone my name is Devon
Wikipedia and I work here at Wolfram as
a kernel developer [ __ ] 4d solve other
functions in bollocks i'm basically
symbolic algorithm developer and with
the last year roughly since the last
conference I've been working on adding
support for symbolic solutions of pds to
dissolve that's been a long-standing
request from many people we know that we
had do it and finally we got down doing
it last year and then we ship 10.2 10.1
10.2 in which we had any eigen system a
very nice beautiful function written by
oliver even Cornick and so in response
to that i added the eigen system to my
project and so today I'm gonna speak
about dissolve and dees all eigen system
in Mathematica 10.3 but I realized that
period is a kind of it's a hard subject
it's something that not even works with
every day so I thought that the docs are
pretty complete you can look at them on
the web on product or wherever and for
myself I I'm going to just present to
you a small kind of tour through the
world of pds using Mathematica 10.3 very
simple examples almost minimal text and
I hope that that will go down well okay
so here's my outline for the talk so the
basic point is i want to show you brand
new examples in version 10.3 4d solve
and yang system but the plan is to first
take on the classical PD is a kind of pd
that you would have seen in a first
course on pd is favored took one the
wave equation the heat equation in the
process equation and if you just done
that people have been really happy with
us that itself is quite a lot but then I
realize that in modern times pd's have
moved on and so I took three examples
for today's talk the first one is
burgers equation from fluid dynamics
which is quite interesting some
nonlinear PD the famous black Scholes PD
from finance which we all know of
recent events last decade or so and the
Schrodinger equation quantum mechanics
which is probably the most important pd
of the 20th century so that's my plan
for the modern stuff and then we go a
bit deeper into desolder look at what
are called sturm-liouville problems so
these are kind of eigen value problems
for ordinary differential equations
again that's been a major problem for us
to solve for a number of years you are
not cracked it completely I think at
least for the second-order OD case and
that will be the third topic for today's
talk and finally I'll talk about the
eigen system in relation to differential
operators so it's very simple plan for
talk let's begin with the wave equation
that's the first classical PD very
simple PD so here's the problem you want
to solve the equation which have strayed
away the wave equation it just says
second partial with respect to time of a
function is equal to second partial
respect to X so to solve it you give
some initial condition so you think of
giving a pulse of some kind because it's
pulse over here and then after that you
called dissolve and that's a pretty
simple equation to solve in fact it was
solved by Dalembert several centuries
ago and that's the solution so the first
part with exponential terms are coming
from the initial condition over here and
the T is coming from the initial
velocity okay so having got the solution
I now plot it and that's a nice plot but
at this point should say that the wave
equation is a basic fundamental example
of what we call a hyperbolic PD so what
are they well hyperbolic PD is one for
which first of all the initial value is
problems well posed so you give initial
values the PD knows what do and it goes
and solves itself okay like a universe
is driven by hydraulic PDS so you create
it and then it goes okay the second
point is that over here you have finite
propagations
speed so if you're a long way out on
this infinite string then it's going to
take a longer time for the pulse to
reach you the third point is you can see
that there are really these two
directions over here which are called
characteristic directions and the PD
kind of evolves along those two
directions and that's why it's called
hyperbolic because there are two of them
not just one and one last point that if
you have initial data which are smooth
then the solution itself is smooth and
conversely if you have sharp initial
data then the solution itself is not
smooth and that's of course what you
expect in the real world you expect your
signals not to get distorted as time
goes by so that's perfect ok so that
simple example actually captures
everything you want to know about
hyperbolic PDE is and I could stop over
there but then it will tell me oh but
real strings are not infinite length so
what happens over there well things
become a lot more complicated and a lot
more interesting so you're the vibrating
string this the first time you can
achieve it in Mathematica without any
work by hand so that's the wave equation
you must specify that the string is
fixed at both the ends and in modern
term you say that's a homogeneous
dirichlet condition I must get some kind
of an initial pull so I pull the string
at some point and let it go and then I
give 2d solve and this takes a bit of
time on this laptop around 32 seconds if
remember right but what's happening over
here is it's calling a sequence of
methods we have layered the code in such
a way that we actually try different
methods and occasionally we might
actually have give up because of the
solution not the right quality my worry
is not people who expert with people who
are doing it's a first course on PDS
they use be solved they get something
that they don't really like so I want
them to get just the right solution so
it takes a bit of time but when it's
done you actually get what one would see
in a typical textbook on PDS and that's
the solution coming from what is called
separation of variables so that's a
solution and you know in version 10 we
had inactive so that's some of their is
inactive to ask questions if you have to
but that some is an inactive some it
doesn't do any
thing until light activated and that
looked to me like the right thing to do
because in textbooks people don't
actually try and evaluate that kind of
some okay so now I must pull off some
stuff from the inactive some so I take
the first four terms and I activate and
what you see over there are some simple
solutions of the wave equation each term
or their solution of wave equation it's
in mathematics you'd say it's separation
of variables in physics you would say
they are standing waves in linear
algebra you might say the eigenfunctions
but that's all the same thing they are
exactly the simple solutions which make
up the solution of the wave equation in
this case so let's plot them and you see
a typical holiday and resnick kind of
illustration over here with the standing
waves for the wave equation and it is a
miracle of fury analysis that you can
put all these together and when you
actually run the animation over here
then the string vibrates smoothly based
on the sum of all those eigen modes so
this is something that's kind of
automated now very easy to do you can do
it for a string you can do it for a drum
it's all documented and I hope that
people will find useful so that's about
the wave equation and now we want the
second example for today which is the
heat equation so here you have that's
the heat equation first partial with
respect to t equal first second partial
spec 2x and then you give an initial
condition which in this case stick to be
peace why it's a box function but you
know that when heat spreads out it
spreads out quite evenly so if i solve
the equation over here then the solution
to get back is in fact going to be not
quite piecewise in facts an error
function solution so if i plot it then
what you get is in nice and smooth
solution so the flow of heat simply
makes everything nice and smooth
instantly the second point you have an
initial value problem which is sore
nicely so the heat equation is an
example of a
bolic pd so we have parabolic PDS but if
you know the heat equation you know them
all basically and you see later on that
the heat equation is of supreme
importance in mathematics okay so you
tell me now that oh that's an infinite
bar in the world bars are not infinite
so you has a finite body got a bar of
iron or whatever you want heat to flow
through it but you would like that the
okay so here's heat equation again now
you want the bar to be insulated both
the ends that's my condition for this
one so I say the derivative on both the
sides of zero and technically that's
called a Roman condition ok and annoyin
n.e you MA and then let's German I guess
no I mean right any anyone German from
yes right look this hungry I'm sorry oh
he was hungry Nia I see I see ok right I
guess it means Newman is that thing ok
so there's deliciously and no I mean
okay right British Lee is boundary and
this is fixed derivative ok now the
initial temperature here is rather
simple ok and what you see that at the
left end the temperature is 20 right in
the temperature is 100 ok so what will
happen as time goes by it's all going to
become 60 if it is a nice regular kind
of bar and so if you solve the equation
that's exactly what do internally figure
if we figure out the steady state
solution and then you see a solution it
will have exactly what we expect it to
be so that's also separation of
variables in this case and for the heat
equation we have several methods but it
will definitely do the right thing for
this kind of simple example so the first
term over here is the steady state
solution and everything else is the
separation of variables from the higher
modes ok so now you take a few terms and
then each term is again a solution of
the heat equation sure
like what I'm using them in for I ghen
value problems as you show a seat later
but I'm happy to change that I mean I
would have loved to yeah you know you
okay I yeah I I did what would kind of
pass review enough okay so right okay I
I picked up as much courage it could and
this okay so okay so now if you plot the
solution you see that initially it's
that blue line over there is the initial
state and then very quickly the bar
balances out and you get the
steady-state solution at 60 degrees
centigrade or whatever okay so that's
the second equation another third
equation Laplace equation which is by
far the hardest to solve it took 25
years or whatever it for ND salt to
learn how to do it and we have taken 26
so we are not doing that badly over here
but here's a Laplace equation ask PETA
he'll tell you that's Laplace in equal
to 0 okay you give some boundary
conditions now there's no time so no
initial conditions is solve the problem
and things go a lot faster you know why
because we do not know much about the
Laplace equation so we do not have that
many methods so things go really fast we
just give up everywhere and then we come
to the right method but what you get
back is again a separation of variable
solution but by now you know the routine
so you pick three hundred terms no harm
and you plot it and what you see now
it's done is a solution which is very
typical of what are called elliptic PDEs
so the Laplace equation is the standard
example for an elliptic PD so what's
elliptic mean Olympic means that first
of all you must give boundary values
that's why you have all this region
functionality in version 10 secondly the
solution becomes instantly smooth it
look like a steady States everything is
nice and smooth the corners at the at
the end and thirdly all the maxima and
minima on the corners there is nothing
middle which is a maximum or minimum so
that simple example captures everything
about elliptic PDEs okay now in version
10 we have the regent functionality and
we have NB solids does PDS over regions
in a wonderfully it's the dramatic
improvement over there so question was
can we do the same for DS all know
historically people think of dissolved
and be solved they never meet okay but
we said let's try and see if you can
meet n be solved in some way or the
other so here's a Laplace equation again
but now I have more modern notation I
talked about the richly condition
instead of boundary condition the same
problem I have a rectangle for the
domain and now with a slightly different
notation from traditional so I say x and
y belong to the rectangle I solve the
equation and hopefully you'll just get
back the same solution okay so then you
again check the redone right thing so
let's just quickly go through that check
this check that and we are done okay now
the nice thing over here at least to me
is that almost so the first time you can
go to the D Sol over here and simply put
an N in front and it goes and call the
sem code and gives back the numerical
solution saudi solve has essentially got
the same syntax now with andy solve at
least in these simple example and
generally speaking if you try an ND Saul
example of DS for example you can flip
notation quite easily now which is a
good thing the long run ok so that's the
classical pds and now we go into more
modern stuff so the first problem is
burgers equation now burgers equation
arose in JM Berger study of turbulence
and turbulence is a great problem Arians
worked on it John Nash total paper on it
called parabolic PD s but if you look at
a paper it
about turbulence everyone who's anyone
worked on turbulence and the simple
truth is you know all of them failed so
far okay so JM burgers in the 1950s
thought he had cracked the problem so
instead of the navier-stokes equations
which are horribly complicated he had
this wonderfully simple quasi-linear
pdes all he was quite happy about it but
if you work in turbulence the last thing
you want is someone to tell you that
your equation has got the closed form
solution and ten years later haughton
cold told him that your equation nothing
but the heat equation and all hopes were
drowned for burger but that equation
contains to be important that so it's
good to study it so that's the initial
condition I take I take a piecewise
initial condition but keep in mind you
on the parabolic domains that's not
going to matter I give it to dissolve
value so you can admire the formula when
it comes out so you hand it off to
integrate and sit back and enjoy the
flight well integrate does all the work
so it takes some time this is hard
integration but it does succeed so it's
the burgers equation with the piecewise
initial condition and essentially course
closed we're sure 10.3 everything I'm
saying today isn't 10.3 no work before
no no no it's all fresh yeah right I
mean it worked on my machine but not
every so and I'm trying to good
introduction to what's there and every
example in this talk is new there's
nothing that's that worked early on
yes I can show documentation in a minute
in fact it's very nicely documented I
think so if you go d-salt page in fact
we wrote the whole d-salt page just for
this project so starting or top
everything is new and if you go down to
that's a good question thank you you go
to scope section and there are sections
can i enlarge a little bit ok so there's
stuff on hyperbolic pd's parabolic pd's
elliptic PDEs general peds period
regions there are applications there is
drum oscillations all kind of stuff over
there so it's pretty complete
documentation away ok so we've found a
solution over here error functions I
plot it and it's nice and smooth now I
know nothing about fluid dynamics so I
asked perrito shimakaze is that
reasonable he said so reasonable but
when you go to the limit as epsilon goes
to zero the viscosity goes to zero then
you start seeing some interesting
behavior so what is seeing over here is
that you have solutions of the burgers
equation and as the viscosity goes to
zero they develop something called a
shock discontinuity which is well known
for a long time but now you can see it
in Mathematica without any work okay so
the second example for today is the
famous black-scholes equation which is
come from finance so around 1973 black
and Scholes wrote a paper which has been
cited 28 thousand seven and 71 times as
of today and they give us one equation
which they believed cracks the whole
problem of pricing options okay so
that's the master model from black
Scholes now let's not worry or what
everything means I am NOT a finance
person there is at least one person way
who is but the point is that in the
original paper black and Scholes said
look this equation is nothing but the
heat equation disguise
so they give a formula for transforming
into the heat equation so but we know
heat equation quite well we can solve it
so I do that over here and you get back
the famous black-scholes formula from
Mathematica by the way the interesting
problem or years to find the value at
some later period of time it is usually
called the expiry date for the option so
that's the capital T over here okay so
then you get some typical values and you
get back a number question what does it
mean well I didn't know that much myself
but then it called finance derivative
which is a built-in function and that
tells you that I am solving a vanilla
European call option model the K in my
model is a strike price the price at the
end of the period the expression time is
one the interest rate for a comparable
asset which is just put in the bank or
whatever is 0.05 etc and financial
derivative actually confirms for me that
the answer is exactly the same okay so
it's nice to have dissolved doing
finance okay so having done finance we
now move on to quantum mechanics and at
this point I kind of was out of my depth
so we called an ETA give who actually
the physicist and he implement the
Schrodinger equation ok that's a
Schrodinger equation we want to model
the electron in a box problem so you
want the electron not leave the box
that's a homogeneous dirichlet condition
I get some initial conditions over here
which is simple enough I solve the
equation and get back a nice solution is
that kind of fully transformed I
I see I see see but you actually have
see reason than getting the solution
from there okay fine okay now max bond
taught us that if you want to study
quantum mechanics don't worry about sigh
worry about the probably density so we
actually do sigh times the complex
conjugate and you get back a probability
density you plug in parameter values so
it is an electron that's electron mass
that's the box it's a very small box
very tiny box and then run animation and
you can see that the electron goes from
side to side in the Box oscillating back
and forth between the two engines it's
this kind of nice demo example that
makes the new functionality really
interesting that we can see all these
things so clearly without much effort
okay now over the years we had an issue
with what are called I ghen value
problems so these eigen value problems
are very simple differential equations
but they are very hard to solve okay so
here's an example they called sturm
liouville problem technically so you
have y double prime plus lambda times y
equal to 0 that's easy exercise a sign
of cosine but then you want y of 0 equal
to 0 and y 0 equal 0 for example now
these equations always has a trivial
solution but sometimes for some values
lambda they also have interesting
solutions and we would happily return 0
for many versions and people complain
and we just kind of you know look the
other way so but now we can actually
solve the problem and we give back what
people expect we give back the
eigenvalues in this case the eigenvalues
are the squares of natural numbers and
paula trances your question about why we
didn't use to formal n because formalin
is used over here so we using to
parameterize the eigen values but
but but I agree with it be nice to have
them elsewhere okay so the eigen
functions you can pull out by giving
values to the lambda parameter and you
can plot them and you get back this
beautiful plot of the eigenfunctions huh
sure sure sure okay so sure okay so
that's an eigenvalue problem lambda is a
parameter it only has solutions for
fixed values of lambda the N is a formal
variable from Mathematica it's / formal
n the advantages if can be assigned
values by some well hopeful people not
do much with it so it just looks like a
textbook n but we cannot use n
internally we are not allowed to so to
speak ok so it's an N from a textbook
basically in Mathematica form okay so
now the problem was that when you go to
harder problems then things really do
get out of hand so here's an example
with what we call a robin condition so
that's a robin condition it is a mixture
of y and y prime and what do you do over
here well we are really stuck because to
find the eigenvalues is very difficult
there are infinitely many of them very
difficult fine so what we do is we
simply give back the eigenvalue equation
over here okay then if you look at a
typical textbook on differential
equations they will then try and solve
the equation by plotting and they'll
find that oh there are two routes
between four and ten but we cannot do
that so we want to automate everything
and so for that reason to introduce the
assumptions option into version 10.3 so
if you see assumptions one less than
lambda less than 10 then you get back
exactly the same solution so you get two
eigenvalues one at about 4.5 the other
one at 7.7 so you can pick your eigen
values by focusing on a particular small
subset of the real line
but this requires a lot of technology
from transferred roots another place
okay so it's not quite non-trivial over
here okay on to my the last part of my
talk which is about I consistence so we
have two new functions the eigen system
in the eigen values which are blatant I
don't know more copies or whatever ND
eigen system and India eigen values they
are the same notation but basically if
you give the eigen system an operator
and a condition and you ask it to find
let us say the first four I ghen
functions eigenvalues it will go and do
that for you in exact form and then you
can plot the results quite easily okay
so here you are the plot is over here
and if you want only the eigenvalues
then you can get the eigenvalues right
over here and the nice thing is once
again i can replace the d eigenvalues by
ND i ignore it simply put an extra n and
you get back the numerical values from
ND eigenvalues so the notation is
parallel to that of india eigenvalues
and actually the functionalities also
roughly the same but of course beyond a
point the numerix just takes off and we
don't have a chance of getting closed
form solutions so as my last example and
just to show you that things can get
really hard but also quite pretty let's
look at the laplacian in a ball so
that's the laplace equation the laplace
operator in three dimensions I say I
want Grizzly boundary conditions that 0
on the boundary I am working on a ball
like the eigenvalues and eigenfunctions
these are known in the literature there
are just a handful which are known in
literature and in one case of the whole
book written on just one particular set
of eigenfunctions the problem is quite
hard we actually so we are trying to
work out the eigen functions for the
laplacian in a ball x-rayed of time
because we need to sort things out and
then to see what this it they look like
let us
take one of them let's good enough for a
talk of this length and I call the new
function density plot 3d a very nice
function from visualization and I let it
go on a laptop like this this is a hard
problem because the function does use a
lot of memory but it should finish up
quite soon but you get really pretty
pictures of these eigenfunctions at
least I haven't seen them before in
Mathematica or elsewhere easily but now
you can plot them so it's plotting now
and when it's done you should see that
you actually can picture the
eigenfunction quite nicely so density
plot 3d really pictures things in 3d as
you know color densities basically so
let's requires a lot of effort bday
let's say I can function so I think
that's quite pretty to come from
dissolve ok so I'm done and the main
point I want to make is that version
10.3 actually introduces a new framework
for solving PDS and from now on if
someone said implement X class of pds we
can do it quite easily without any
problems but what we have done now could
not have been possible but for the
developments in visualization numerics
and in symbolic computation in fact
we've been writing lots of these super
functions over the last few releases and
we can do to some confidence without
breaking everyone's examples you know so
so far no notice any problems the D saw
which are you got is a healthy thing ok
but the main point to me is that we have
actually addressed a very large number
of requests from our users whether it be
Stephen Wolfram himself manager of QA
stack exchange I have emails for
everyone and I just hide my face and say
no we cannot do at the moment you know
but now with a straight face we can you
know tell me just try matt bell 10.3 and
we are done but believe me it's it's
kind of taken a big burden of me to have
to see that we can't do these things so
on that note I will stop but before I do
that here is a
summary of today's talk so we learned
about hyperbolic pd's parabolic pd's
elliptic PDEs modern peds and
eigenfunctions so